- [Narrator] This submarine
is what experts are calling
the future of underwater defense.
It's a nuclear powered attack sub
that combines next-gen UK design
with classified US technology,
and it's being built in Australia
where it'll be deployed in the 2040s.
- The US doesn't usually share
this type of technology with its allies,
so the fact that Australia's
getting it is a massive deal.
- [Narrator] But the future subs,
which are estimated to
cost up to $250 billion,
have been criticized by China and Russia,
who say the vessels risk sparking
a nuclear arms race in the Indo-Pacific.
So here's the secret US technology
that will enhance these subs,
and how it might be used
to counter China's growing influence.
The SSN-AUKUS is being built
with one key feature in
mind, interoperability.
That's the ability for all three nations
to integrate the same technology,
weapons, and nuclear
reactors into their subs.
To do this, the US will share
its highly classified
nuclear submarine technology,
making the UK and Australia
the only two nations
to ever publicly receive these systems.
Australia will also
become the seventh country
in the world to own these vessels,
which have greater capabilities
than their current
diesel-electric submarines.
- They can go farther, they
can generally go faster
and they're quieter as well,
so there's a big capability advantage
in a maritime environment.
- [Narrator] Naval experts
say the submarine's design
will likely feature a larger hull
than Australia's current submarines,
housing almost twice as many crew members.
That crew will operate US
combat control systems,
which detect the submarine's surroundings
and direct its weapons to their targets.
Alongside US torpedoes,
those weapons will include missiles fired
from vertical launch systems.
Experts say these multipurpose
silos will be similar
to the modules used in US
Virginia class submarines
(explosion bangs and hisses)
allowing all three nations
to use the same US tomahawk
and hypersonic missiles.
- Strapping a American missile
into an Australian submarine
and having it work absolutely seamlessly
would be a great advantage
in any military conflict.
- [Narrator] All of these
weapons will be conventional,
as Australia doesn't have nuclear weapons.
That means building the
nuclear reactors needed
to power these subs on its
own shores could violate
the 1968 Nuclear Non-Proliferation Treaty.
The treaty limits the transfer and use
of highly enriched uranium
to non-nuclear weapon states,
so Australia will use what
critics have called a loophole
for the first time in
the treaty's history.
The power units will
instead be built in the UK
by Rolls Royce and
enhanced with US technology
to make them safer and quieter.
They'll then be completely sealed
before being shipped to Australia.
This arrangement has sparked
concerns from campaigners
who want to stop the
spread of nuclear weapons,
and drawn criticism from China and Russia.
(speaking in foreign language)
- China has said this could lead
to an arms race in the region.
Obviously the US and
Australia deny those claims,
but Russia and China do
not like this deal at all.
- [Narrator] That's because of
tensions in the Indo-Pacific,
where the AUKUS Alliance says
these subs will be deployed.
Experts say choke points,
including the Sunda Strait
and Taiwan Strait, as well
as the South China Sea,
are the primary zones of
interest for these subs.
- The way that the US is
seeking to counter China
in the region is that
they're trying to build up
the capabilities of their allies,
and this is one of the ways
that the US is doing that.
- [Narrator] But critics say
that all this advanced
technology could be obsolete
by the time the SSN-AUKUS
is actually deployed.
Experts have pointed to the
rapid development of UUVs,
or unmanned underwater vehicles,
as both a challenge to the
importance of submarines
and an opportunity for
their continued relevance.
- You might have one-man
submarines sort of controlling
a fleet of underwater drones,
but when you're looking
at such a big timeframe,
20 years in the future,
it's unclear how much
of a need there will be.
- [Narrator] That uncertainty
and the significant price
tag attached to these vessels
has raised the eyebrows of critics,
but experts say the high
cost shows how important
a stronger presence in the Indo-Pacific is
for the AUKUS Alliance.
- There is a growing recognition
that the US cannot do this alone,
China's been pouring a
lot of money and time
into its military buildup,
and to keep pace with China,
the US is going to have to
seek help from its allies
and Australia really is
one of its biggest allies in the region.